So this is breaking news right now.
The United States just used its superpower veto
to not allow Palestine membership into the United Nations.
That is absolutely ridiculous.
Everybody has the right to sit at the United Nations to speak,
have a voice and vote and everything.
This is an abuse of the superpower veto.
This is completely unnecessary.
Every group of people has a right at the United Nations
to speak and be heard. Everybody.
And really, it's of no interest for America to be even doing this.
It doesn't benefit us, it doesn't hurt us.
We should be completely neutral to this topic.
We're only doing it because.
For APEX, for Israel.
And that's what makes it even more ridiculous.
Acts like this undermine the United Nations as an assembly
and as an effective group.
It makes the United Nations less effective,
and it also makes America look bad.